Cheryl Sandberg actually called me out
on this I was at a meeting and I said
something in front of the other
Executives and she said
afterwards she pulled me aside she said
you can stop fighting now you've won
and she realized it wasn't about
fighting for your rights it was actually
I was just fighting everyone and she's
like wow you're feeding everyone around
you you need to back off and it took me
a long time to understand what she was
saying but it was so transformative to
me because that fight was everything I
had and I had to find a new identity
what am I fighting for now at the time
that kind of that that power of like
being angry and upset at how I grew up
was rocket fuel because it drove me to
succeed to be ambitious to do all the
things
and then suddenly it was starting to
burn me up and it was starting to hurt
my relationships and I had to really
retool and figure out where I wanted to
go from there
[Music]
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast the CEO of ancestry which is a
giant tech company we'll talk about and
the author of the important new book
take back your power 10 new rules for
women at work Deb Liu welcome Deb
thanks for inviting me it's great to be
here Andrew
um it's so great to be able to connect
uh so you are the CEO of a really
significant company I think at one point
it was a public company it might have
gotten taken private you might know it
as ancestry.com
um I've seen it referred to as ancestry
which is probably a little bit broader
uh what is ancestry you know ancestry is
the world's leading genealogy company
but we also specialize in helping people
tell their family histories and discover
their family history so most people know
us because UAB tried to build a family
tree or if you've actually done a DNA
test where actually the world's largest
consumer genomics company hidden in a
family history company as well and so it
is a way to show how the human race has
been connected to each other in many
ways we never imagined wow so did you
use it you showed up that you're like I
better I I better test it out well you
know one of the things I did when I was
interviewing for this role is I had I
had done the DNA test but I really
wanted to build my family history and I
invited all my cousins I built out you
know what I had and I started the family
storytelling and actually uploaded all
the photos that my cousins had collected
over the years and started tagging them
and telling their stories and so it's
been a great adventure I think we still
have more to do for the minority
communities especially those whose
parents are immigrants but one of the
things that's just been really unfolding
the story of our family one piece at a
time
I I confess I have not used it in part
because
um I think my family be really boring uh
you know my dad grew up on a farm in
Taiwan so it's like farmer Farmer
Farmers what I'm imagining
but I should definitely uh test test it
out so you all must have changed a lot
of lives do you have any particularly
memorable or uplifting uh customer
accounts yeah I mean we have so many
great stories I mean we've helped people
connect there was one woman who found a
book with her um her father's book from
the Holocaust and actually had the names
of those who was there with them and
actually she didn't know how to contact
them so she went on Ancestry and
actually found them contacted them and
actually did a reunion with the children
and grandchildren who had been with her
father and so these are just the stories
a few of the stories of how people just
use our service in different ways we
never imagined actually and it's really
exciting I have never been to a dinner
party where someone didn't tell me an
amazing ancestry story and that's
actually what attracted me to take this
role well so you had an incredible
career Arc leading up to it uh you
worked at PayPal eBay and then facebook
slash meta
um so you must have been in very high
Dem man I mean again ancestry is a
really significant Enterprise where
there are other roles you were
considering like what where what
juncture was your career at when you
took this role you know I had
Facebook now meta and I built a lot of
things there I worked on games and
payments I had built Facebook
Marketplace they built the first um
direct response ads product as well as
the advertising Network and I realized
at some point you know is there another
chapter for me here and as I was looking
I actually talked to several companies
about CEO roles and but there was
something about answer issues felt right
it was something I really cared about
which was family history my family is so
important to me and still very close to
everybody despite the fact that we live
all over the world and so this company
really spoke to me when I first started
talking to them and as I got deeper into
it I could just see the possibilities
and you know since I've been there the
work that we've been doing is actually
building ancestry for all you know our
product is really amazing if you come
from European background we still have
work to do if you don't and so you know
really building ancestry for all and
also me to we like you know it's really
a solo research product when I first got
here and now really kind of building it
so that people can actually share that
with their families because you know
they you know people tell me stories of
how their mother will actually pull out
their computer and turn it around so
people can see their discoveries and I
said you know we can bring that into the
Modern Age and actually bring you on to
the platform so you can see these
discoveries real time and so a lot of
the work we've been doing has been just
building a more communal kind of
family-oriented product than not just a
solo activity well you're an expert in
building massive social products that
reach millions and millions of people So
Meta has been through something of an
arc I I feel like it's true for a lot of
Silicon Valley and you've been there for
a while like what do you think of the uh
I guess shifting perceptions of Silicon
Valley there are people that you know
who work at all of these firms I know
people too like in my mind most everyone
who works at these companies uh wants to
do good things uh you know it's very
hard to argue that ancestry is anything
but benevolent honestly it's applying
you know information about people's uh
family trees but what is your sense of
silicon Valley's I suppose the the place
in the public Consciousness over the
last number of years you know the one
thing is everyone who's at these
companies like you said really wants to
build great things I mean I built
Facebook Marketplace that connects over
a billion people to buy and sell from
each other because I just knew that
there was a possibility that people
could actually do community Commerce and
there's less waste in the world and yet
there were times when people took
advantage of each other on the platform
not because that was what we intended
but because you know people have stolen
from each other or hurt each other and
that is not a good thing and there are
frauds and scams and things that we need
to keep in mind when we're building for
so many people because when you bring
Humanity together there's good and
there's bad but you know one of the
things that's really important is that
what are we trying to achieve and how do
we actually assure that the good is
where we are focusing but also that
we're actually protecting people from
things and harms that can happen as well
and so each of these choices we make is
how much are you investing and making
sure you have the great experience and
yet at the same time protect from the
negative experiences at the same time
it's not always easy though because how
do you know what the those experiences
are going to be I mean there was one
experience on Facebook marketplace where
in one country people started selling
diplomas and we thought well how is that
even the thing you know yeah
but in there in one country diplomas are
actually kind of like driver's licenses
so it was like fake identification and
we had to decide well do we ban diplomas
worldwide do we ban the word do we and
these are this seems to be an innocuous
choice and yet it was one country where
this was a problem and we had to make a
decision for either that language that
country for the world and it was a micro
choice that we had to make but imagine
that at ten thousand a hundred thousand
of these decisions made by people who
really really want to do the right thing
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
what the heck is Helix sleep it is the
mattress of the future company I have
always been someone who valued my sleep
figured you know you're gonna do it for
seven maybe even eight hours you wake up
feeling refreshed and energized what is
that worth Helix sleep can help make
that happen just take their sleep quiz
and figure out what personalized
mattress should be shipped straight to
your door and you have a hundred days to
return it I don't recommend returning it
after 99 days but hey who am I to say
don't take my word for it it's the
number one rated mattress from GQ and
wired can you imagine being the mattress
tester it's a job someone has it Helix
is offering 20 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
right now go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep start
hurts now
[Music]
yeah I mean that's like a good
illustration because it's something we
would never think of but then you
imagine that extrapolated to hundreds of
countries and uh different categories uh
so you wrote a really important book
take back your power 10 new rules for
women at work uh there are a bunch of
stories in here that I'm very excited to
dig in with you but one of them was
about how you showed up at Facebook as a
product manager which is a very
important role and fewer than 10 percent
of the product managers of the time were
women and you saw that and said huh like
that that can't be right and then you
set about trying to to change that with
a lot of success over time uh so uh how
did that evolve and how did you manage
to frankly get attention to a problem
that a lot of people might have just
looked at and said like huh
um you know that's just like the State
of Affairs you know the story is
actually worse than that in fact I
couldn't come in as a product manager
because I didn't qualify I didn't have a
computer science degree even though I
ran the buyer experience at eBay as the
product lead and actually that happened
to a lot of people so you know the story
was a lot of us who started in product
management early on actually you know
were did not have technical degrees I
have an engineering degree but in civil
engineering and so if you want me to
build you a house we can talk about it
but I can't really actually encode
anything and so so it was so specific
they said hey it's not even an
engineering background it's literally
computer science correct it's a computer
science degree and you know and they had
a technical interview as well and you
know again a lot of us didn't qualify
and so we had many of us who started you
know by the way 20 of computer science
degrees in America are earned by women
and so suddenly people had had amazing
product careers couldn't get their next
job
and it was because one company made a
place in 2004 Google said we really want
technical PMS we didn't want them to
have a computer science degree and it
made sense for the evolution of where
they were at the time but that every
company copied it and it didn't
necessarily make sense for everybody
else and so over the years a lot of
people couldn't get their next job a lot
of people who came out of school without
a computer science degree couldn't enter
product
suddenly you're in this kind of you know
you're in this progress has like
completely slowed those of us who worked
early on a lot of the VP is a product
actually were women and you know at one
point the entirety of Amy Clement's uh
product team at PayPal all the directors
were women sitting around her table and
none of us could probably get another
job and product for a period of time and
so we ended up doing a lot of other
things I came in as a product marketer
and eventually was invited into product
and then I looked around and said we're
all the women here and you know luckily
I had such great support and I you know
talked to the head of recruiting I
talked to the CPO and I said hey we can
change this but we need to make these
changes so one was dropping the computer
science degree two was dropping the
technical interview
and three was just really changing the
way we interviewed to actually look for
things that were high signal not just
things that we thought we were looking
for so you had great ground to stand on
because you were actually already
successful in the role and you could say
or you could say with authority it's
like look guys you know you could
clearly can be excellent as a product
manager without having this particular
qualification but I dare say it must
have been really difficult to get
someone to change that requirement I
think you might have written a LinkedIn
post that that actually asked hey guys
why are there so few women in product
and then it ended up igniting uh this
entire conversation that must have felt
um frankly uh like a risk at the time uh
you know like is it it seems a little
bit like you're you know you're I mean
again like you're arguing a case where
it's like look guys like I clearly can
do this job
this this uh this qualification may not
make sense but uh did you expect to get
as much attention as it did
well what fascinated me was first it
took me four years to write that the
article because every time I thought
about it you know the bug was put in my
ear by actually April Underwood who at
one point was the head of product for
slack and you know what she said was you
know I was I was you know technical
enough to be a product manager for many
years and then suddenly I couldn't go
into Google as a product manager and we
talked long and extensively about it and
we realized that it wasn't us that the
system had changed beneath us and we had
no idea
and you know I wrote that article and I
kept thinking I can't be the only person
who notices this I finally published it
and you know I had the full support of
Facebook to do it I had we had been
making changes over the years already
when I was heading up product recruiting
but when I published it the comments
were incredible so many people
especially women said you know what I
thought it was just me I couldn't get my
next job I couldn't Advance I've left
the industry or I've left the role
because I couldn't make progress but
suddenly we realized it was a systemic
choice that the industry had made and
the wrong choice in my mind and you know
now a lot of companies have dropped the
computer science requirement and product
managers are not worse they're better
because now we can draw from so many
different backgrounds so many incredible
product managers I work with don't come
from a computer science background and
that's absolutely okay I think of the
product managers when we did a survey at
women in product it was something like
only 30 percent had either computer
science or even a technical degree like
engineering which meant that 70 of the
people in the audience who were active
in the industry didn't qualify for their
own jobs at one point and I was thinking
that's such a tragedy yeah you clearly
need different perspectives uh to build
products that work for everyone and you
have some stories in the book about how
uh early on in Facebook you said hey
guys you might want to have a status
called expecting for when you're
pregnant and then the people looked at
you like why on Earth would anyone want
to do that and then years later they
were like oh yeah that was a pretty uh
good call by you yeah you know I I think
we just we just need to bring more
diversity to the table and at the time
when I joined the country company I had
two kids I had a newborn and a toddler
and so I just saw the world really
differently right I was the only mom PM
for many many years and you know I could
see such opportunity for Facebook to be
so powerful for moms because I could see
that world like I but I know I asked the
product manager what do you do when you
find out you're expecting you want to
announce it to your friends and he's
like what and he said you post a picture
of the ultrasound and he's like why
would you do that and then later he had
kids and he's like I get it now and the
point is it's not because he's not
brilliant it's because he just didn't
have that life experience that and it
was just a diverse life experience that
I had had and the same thing with
Facebook Marketplace I kept telling
people I buy and sell a ton of stuff on
Facebook and they're like why would
anyone want to buy anything here and but
I wasn't part of all these mom groups
where we traded things because you have
so much stuff when you have kids and you
just keep recycling things and you know
I'm like how many bicycles can you
really put in your garage before you run
out of space and so one of the things I
did was quite quite a few by the way
actually have a whole plan around that
which is you buy a bicycle the kids use
it when they outgrow it you sell it back
in the marketplace it's like rental plan
to find it it's a great plan and you
don't have to store all of it and so I
had done this for years and I realized
that other people couldn't see it
because they didn't have kids at the
time and now that once people had kids
they understood what I was talking about
but this is why diversity matters
because you can see the worlds from
different perspectives and build
products that are more inclusive for
people who might not already be at the
company
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
you write about being an introvert
growing up uh child of immigrants I
could relate to both of those things for
sure uh and and then you uh talk about
how you took a class at
um Stanford Business School uh that
really changed your mindset
um I actually interviewed Jeff pfeffer
whom I met through you who's the
Stanford professor and the class asked
okay what is the thing you're going to
do differently as a result of this class
in your career and you wrote down I'm
going to be an extrovert at work which
is a very very big deal uh you know I
have to say uh that that's a massive
deliberate choice and I can relate to
aspects of this because I was a very
introverted uh bookish kid
uh I stepped into the public Spotlight
in a way that demanded a certain degree
of extroversion and my team had to get
accustomed to the fact that I was still
natively an introvert and so I would do
a bunch of press or or events and then
afterwards I just want to be alone
[Laughter]
honestly and some of them
were not introverts so they're like oh
like you know like this is an adjustment
the fact that you consciously said
having to be an extrovert at work I have
to say there are a lot of introverts
listening to this or watching this right
now that that makes them wince in pain
um there are certainly a belief among
some people that the goal when you go to
work is to be quote unquote uh you know
who you are your natural self and so it
might seem uh like asking a lot for
someone to subvert their their nature so
what made you uh commit to that
resolution uh and do do you advise other
people who are introverts who come to
you because I'm sure a lot of people
have come to you now for uh career
advice do you actually say to them hey
you might you might want to actually uh
take a different attack at work
you know I wrote this article called The
Secret bias no one talks about and it's
along the lines of Susan Kane's quiet
which is we have this massive bias in
our society in American society we
really value people who speak up you
know think about who is charismatic
who's out there who we pick as our
politicians people who pick we for CEO
you know we don't pick the person who's
quietly doing the work with behind the
scenes we're picking the person who can
stand up on stage and inspire people
right or wrong
and one of the things I I had to learn
in that class at Stanford was I had to
learn that you know that yes
introversion is a state you know we
actually have a trade and ancestry for
introversion versus extroversion and
mine is like extremely introverted and
yet at the same time I treat it like
learning a language if I had to learn a
different language to be successful you
know if I if I wanted to run a division
and it was in Spain and I had to learn
Spanish I would go do it so I just treat
it as a second language it doesn't have
to be amazing
translate I would list love I just want
to understand what that world is but I
don't have to live in that world I still
dream in my native language but at the
same time I can learn a different
language if absolutely necessary to be
successful and to persuade others and I
realize you know just like you have gone
through this Evolution you know you know
you've had gotten on stage in front of
50 million people and done something
that no one who's introverted would ever
have thought to do and yet at the same
time you did it because it was a
necessity for what you hope to
accomplish in your life and the change
that you hope to make and the voice that
you want to have and this is the same
thing for me which is we can choose to
be introverted and you know say this is
who I am or we can say I'm going to
learn this new skill that's going to be
to help me connect with other people and
when you put it that way Suddenly It's
well you know it's a skill and it's
helping me connect with other people
it's not about selfishness or giving
it's actually about the opportunity to
get out of our own heads and say how can
we help others to be more comfortable
yeah I mean it's very powerful and
personal but I have to say the facts are
the facts you know when your book has
some data uh Jeff pfeffer's book
certainly has a ton of data about the
fact that uh certain behaviors do help
you make connections with folks who can
help Advance your careers
um one episode you recount in your book
is around sponsors uh and there was a
male executive who noticed that or
actually you told him he was like hey
why don't you talk more in these
meetings and you're like actually I do
talk and then I get cut off anytime I do
it and then he's like what and then he
paid attention the next time and then
saw someone cut you off and then the
person who cut you off then reached out
to you individually later to apologize
you realized it was because this male
sponsor actually nudged him and said hey
man you're totally cutting step off but
I mean you know maybe you did it to
other women too in some cases it's
helpful to have Ally is in what you call
sponsors that that help clear the way
yeah I mean first of all we we talk
about mentors and sponsors mentors give
you advice and sponsors open doors and
they're the ones who take action and in
this case my manager I mean he was a
great manager by the way even before
this but he just sounds great
you know before he but one thing that
really
I try to talk because I had committed to
being an extrovert at work so I tried
but in the meetings we were in he
noticed I wasn't talking and so every
you know so I tried to speak a couple
times and he realized I was cut off
immediately but what he did was so
powerful which is he said I see you and
I'm going to address this so he didn't
actually tell me he was going to do this
but the next town was cut off
that person apologized and I said he
reached out to you didn't he and I
thanked him because behind the scenes
he's making it easier for someone like
me who's extremely you know I'm already
introverted and so every time I got
spoken over in my head I was like what
if I'm saying something wrong what if
you know I'm not smart enough and I was
internalizing the feedback of getting
cut off as saying hey maybe you're not
good enough whereas maybe an extrovert
wouldn't have reacted that way but it
helped me to really see that I needed
somebody to say you know what I have
your back and I have your back right now
and I'm gonna have your back every
single time that this happens again and
by the way it never happened again
because he was he was actually there
making sure it wasn't going to happen in
this meeting well I'm sure that we're
under the word got out in that group
it's like hey guys you know like uh
uh cutting Deb off or cutting the female
uh managers or Executives off is is a
No-No in in This Crew which obviously uh
is a vital message you had an incredible
story in the book about how there was a
guy you just did not get on with at all
um you found yourself uh really really I
think you're your exact words were like
look if I had to work for that guy I
would just quit my job
um and then uh Facebook kind of put you
two together
um and you had to have what struck me as
almost it was almost like a marriage
counseling like a work marriage
counseling which by the way reading this
I was just like oh my gosh does this
sound like a lot of people's worst
nightmare
maybe because there are a lot of people
who would leave their job frankly if
they were forced to work with someone
um that they had such bad chemistry with
um and they managed to get you two to
get to the bottom of the dynamic
um uh in a way that I frankly I thought
was remarkable like I hadn't seen much
of it in a corporate setting I've run
teams and I don't think I would have I
don't think I don't think I would have
been like hey guys uh you know I mean I
I've certainly done this like one time
and like hey look you guys got to work
it out like I've done something like
that but I I didn't take it to the
extent that uh that that your team did
um and I thought it was really
incredible for you to share uh that
story
um uh and have that person willing to
participate as well because uh like it
seemed like exactly the kind of work
situation that most people
um actively dread uh can you talk a
little bit about how you managed to make
that as success well you know I I said
you know there's always one person so
I've asked you they're one person that
you would rather quit than report to
well this was that person for me and
everyone knew it by the way and so when
my manager was leaving he said by the
way you know you're going to report to
Boz Boz is now the CTO of meta and I
said I'd rather quit Okay
I texted my husband and I said I'm gonna
have to quit my job and he's like what
happened and I said I have to report to
Boz and he said oh I understand I mean
this is I had a really great career I
was really happy there and
um the next thing my manager said is
Mark wants to talk to you and so I went
to Mark's office and he said I know how
you feel about each other I mean the
thing that everyone knew this too was
crazy to me but it was uh Mark you went
I mean Cheryl had gotten us into
previous counseling before so we it was
well known that we struggled with our
relationship and yet you know we we had
made it work by staying as far away from
each other as possible and yet we've
worked on things that overlapped
actually and so it was a really
frustrating experience for both of us
because I respect him so much he's
brilliant but we were just so different
like how we saw the world how we
interact with each other and you know
they said can you just give it three
months and so I said okay and we sat
down and we worked through you know so
much of how we see someone else is
through our own experience and I told
him I really struggle with his style he
was extremely aggressive he's just
really big guy with a big voice and he
completely intimidated me and so every
time he spoke I just had this visceral
reaction and he was somebody who's just
a bigger than life personality and a lot
of times he would ask questions in this
pointed way I just felt constantly kind
of on the defense and because I was
Defensive he would push harder because
that was his way of getting to the
answer and he's just like oil and water
no matter what we did we would just you
know be on the wrong side and in the end
I said look this is what I want if we
want to if I'm gonna report to you this
is what I need and I wrote it out and
actually sent him an email and he's like
you're welcome to send a copy to HR if
you'd like and then he said that I'm
asking one thing of you I want you to
write something and post it every month
in our internal channels and I'm like
that is a very strange ask because I had
written a very long like document with
multiple points and what we agreed to
and he's like that's the only thing I
want from you
and I said okay if that's what you ask I
will do it and you know he lived up to
his side of the commitment I lived up to
my side of the commitment I realized you
know one of the things that we committed
to was if there was ever a single
inkling of us being off the same page we
would immediately contact each other and
we did and suddenly we realized that so
much of our relationship was a
misunderstanding built on a
misunderstanding and in the end he
actually you know I lived up to my
commitment I wrote way more I never had
really written and published and when I
wrote this book I asked him if I could
actually tell our story and he helped me
do it he actually helped me write this
chapter of the book and so you know it
doesn't always end perfectly but you
know in this case where two people are
really trying you can find find a way to
work together it really is possible
foreign
we are living in the era of big Tech AI
chat GPT generative tools and these big
tech companies have made it a habit to
pick up everything we are doing online
why should they get our data and where
left out in the cold it's reasons like
this that I use expressvpn to hide my
unique IP address to make it harder for
big Tech to track me and my identity and
activity and encrypt all of my online
comings and goings and it's not like you
have to be a tech whiz to use expressvpn
literally just tap one button on your
phone or computer to activate it you
don't want your family to be vulnerable
and one subscription to expressvpn
covers me my wife and my kids on up to
five devices so stop letting big Tech
leech on your data freely use my link
expressvpn.com yang right now and you
can get three extra months free that's
exp r e s s vpn.com Yang to get
protected with a VPN rated number one by
CNET tech radar and most importantly me
expressvpn.com yang
[Music]
I mean it's a pretty good metaphor for
uh you know like larger conflict
resolution maybe organization-wide or or
even at this point society-wide given
what uh a lot of the the countries going
through uh so you are you write about
being Christian in the book in a way
that I think is unusual for what some
might think of as a business book
um you certainly get very personal in
the book you talk about your marriage uh
to to Dave who seems like a you know a
phenomenally uh supportive partner you
guys have have traded off in terms of UH
responsibilities around the the family
over the last number of years I have
friends who are Christian in Tech a
couple of them have told me stories
where I'm like whoa that doesn't seem
cool where where I guess they're like
assumptions that people make about
Christians have you had any experiences
in in that direction I think you were
even the head of uh like a
Christian professional uh group at
Facebook you know I actually people have
been so gracious and part of it I wear a
cross
you know people will come up to me and
share with me their thoughts and
sometimes it's hard to hear I mean
people have been hurt by the church and
there have been many people who
who have been hurt by religion at
various points in their lives and and I
I share this quote with fellow
Christians which is you know Gandhi said
I would be Christian but for the fact
that I've met Christians and you know we
are in in perfect faith and there are a
lot of imperfect people who are still
figuring out their way and so but so
many people have been so gracious to
open the door to a conversation and
share that hurt with me and to say you
know I don't understand can you help me
and I have you know sat down and said
hey I hear you and I hear the pain that
you've experienced and let's talk about
it but you know very few people have
ever broad brushed I mean they're
hubbing people who are surprised though
they say but you're so reasonable and
I'm like um I think you just made this
assumption that I would not be
reasonable but let's talk and I think
it's how we approach this you know when
you approach it in the in the spirit of
relationship and the spirit of care
people are open to having the
conversation and hearing you know
different perspectives but I think when
we say well you know what you know it's
it's you either Believe it or you don't
you know that's that is not how we look
at the worlds how how I see um what I
believe is that other people are open to
having the conversation why am I not
open to having the conversation around
what I believe as well and so and you
know not everyone has to believe exactly
the same thing but they I wish that we
opened the door to hearing where we each
came from because that's how we journey
through life together well it's a
beautiful message and we're not one of
the most important messages in your book
I thought was this message of
forgiveness uh you don't hear a lot
about forgiveness in business or or
politics it is a deeply uh Christian
idea and you write about forgiving
yourself uh in a way that I also thought
was very powerful
um you seem to have a bit of uh I I
don't think this is you know like out of
turn given given the book but you seem
to have a bit of a chip on your shoulder
or
um uh in part because you grew up one of
the uh lone
um immigrant families uh in South
Carolina in a context where uh you were
very acutely aware of your identity and
this is something I also can relate to
Growing Up in Upstate New York in the
70s as one of the lone Asian families uh
you know like I had a lot of uh teasing
and
um some fights uh you know kid kids are
generally uh pretty quick to point out
differences uh with other kids and you
write about having to forgive yourself
and then also forgiving others uh and
having that actually is something that
helped fuel your ability to to make
positive things happen in the world yeah
you know I do think that we we don't
talk about forgiveness in the workplace
or or and of ourselves way nearly enough
I mean for me I absolutely had a chip on
my shoulder I grew up in a place where
people would come up to my parents
adults not even kids you'd go back to
where you came from and in my mind I
would think New York because I'm from
New York
um I grew up in Queens and I just
remember thinking how could people
actually say that to someone else that
they don't even know and yet you know I
spent my whole childhood being othered
being that person who ate strange food
and you know didn't quite fit in and was
always you know no matter where I went
people would just ask questions about
you know that felt really intrusive and
and I really struggled with the bullying
and all of those things and yet I
realized that for me I just protected
myself right I built a hard shell if I
was just really quiet and I had a hard
shell and nobody could could penetrate
then I would win and I realized that
when you become when you know when you
kind of protect yourself by building
this wall it becomes impenetrable for
you to exit either also and so if I had
to really work through that and Cheryl
Sandberg actually called me out on this
I was at a meeting and I said something
in front of the other Executives and she
said
afterwards she pulled me aside she said
you can stop fighting now you've won
and she realized it wasn't about
fighting for your rights it was actually
I was just fighting everyone and she's
like wow you're fighting everyone around
you you need to back off and it took me
a long time to understand what she was
saying but it was so transformative to
me because that fight was everything I
had and I had to find a new identity
well what am I fighting for now and so I
had to really find a lot of Grace in
that and and I have over the years that
at the time that kind of that that power
of like being angry and upset at how I
grew up was rocket fuel because it drove
me to succeed to be ambitious to do all
the things
and then suddenly it was starting to
burn me up and it was starting to hurt
my relationships and I had to really
retool and figure out where I wanted to
go from there
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even and I became friends
and thought we should collaborate on a
way to scare the out of people but
also entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andrewyang.com books and there's
a special discount code last election
that you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
yeah you write about uh getting down on
yourself or being an imperfect parent by
the way I mean you know we're both
parents so like you screw up every uh
you know few days probably in some form
my kids would say every
yeah I have to stop beating myself up
over that uh and it'll make me a better
parent and then you realize wait a
minute that actually applies to a lot of
other things
um in life too I'll share with you when
I was younger I used to braid myself uh
for a mistake oftentimes a mistake that
only I would notice like mistakes that
other people didn't didn't even see uh
and being able to let that sort of thing
go became necessary for me to be able to
uh put myself out there or do certain
things because you're going to screw up
um all the time in that context and if
you're an introvert I think a lot of
introverts are naturally kind of hard on
themselves that way uh so I could relate
very much to this lesson
um because I when someone asked me a
while ago it's like hey how were you uh
how did you have to evolve to put
yourself out in public life and I said I
just had to stop being so hard on myself
that is absolutely true I think so often
we're the hardest on ourselves more than
anybody else I remember when you know I
was growing up I was the one who said I
got a 99 what happened to the last point
I was my parents actually your parents
Deb come on actually the Asian parents
they're actually way more laid back
why do you study so hard but I had this
internal drive to I was when I was in
third grade I'm like I'm gonna graduate
first in my class so I can get a
scholarship to college what third grader
actually sits there and plots no one
third grade
but for me it was my only escape from
something I really really struggled with
this is rural South Carolina right yeah
it was a small town in South Carolina
it's about 45 minutes outside of
Charleston and you know I just really
struggled with what it was like to grow
up being different I said I'm going to
go to a place where I'm accepted but in
order to get there I had to get to
College my parents could only help me so
much so I'm like I'm gonna graduate
number one I'm gonna go to college I'm
going to get a scholarship and I'm never
going to come back here and so much of
that is that that Rocket Fuel I talked
about right that drive to like break
through every barrier and that helped me
until it no longer helps me so I was a
perfectionist and an introvert which is
you know maybe two things that are too
much compatible in some ways and so I
had to really let go of that because in
parenting in particular there is no
perfect and they'll let you know when
you're not perfect
uh so I've been to South Carolina a
whole lot
um because I I campaigned there
during the 2020 race it's in the news
politically right now it's going to be
one of the first dates
for really both parties but uh you know
I guess the Republican party will be a
little bit more interesting and
competitive uh Nikki Haley is going to
run for oh she's already out there in
South Carolina Tim Scott's going to
declare in a minute
um and a lot of the rest of the country
maybe might have a certain sense of
South Carolina from the outside looking
in
um do you still have ties to the state
and and what do you think about uh I
suppose it being one of the places that
helps determine who the presidential
nominees are you know when I was growing
up nobody ever heard of the state of
South Carolina when I told people when I
you know left the state
um where I was from they're like oh
that's near North Carolina I'm like yes
it's just south of it yeah you know
because nobody it was not known for
anything in particular so it's so
amazing to hear people talk about my
home state in in such terms that people
actually want to visit people are
actually seeing you for what it could be
you know the one thing I did love about
South Carolina it's a beautiful place
it's really generous people you know not
everybody was terrible it was actually a
place of southern hospitality great food
and just like so much culture and so
much history and so it's amazing to see
people go there but also it's a very
complicated history the plantations the
slave markets you know something like a
third of the slaves who entered this
country came from the Port of Charleston
and so
you know that was something which we had
to confront and South Carolina we all
studied South Carolina history and we
had to learn a lot of the really painful
history of what happened there even now
with the Emmanuel Amy Church which I
write about in my book you know that
happened in Charleston and it's a
reminder that we still have a long way
to go as we as we kind of look at our
history and also move forward but I'm
glad people are are going there and
learning about that history and
confronting some of the challenges and
especially you know two leaders who are
who are minorities from South Carolina
running in the Republican race will
actually you know open the door to
having those conversations yeah I've
been to Charleston I've been to that
building where slaves were brought in
and sold uh and you feel this history
and and frankly like you know like this
this sad energy from that place because
there's just so much human uh suffering
and misery uh that that that took place
there but also agree with you that that
there are a lot of warm uh friendly
people it's a beautiful state in some
ways uh you know I mean it's a
complicated place
um I I will say that when it's on my
schedule which it is every once in a
while like I do enjoy it like I have
friends there and and head down there
and and look forward to it and even my
family came down and campaigned one time
I think they might have hit the beach
though and something I think it was one
of those situations where there's like
one of the most beautiful beaches in the
world are in South Carolina yeah yeah
it's a very very
um yeah it's a nice Beach so that way if
you know if you visited those
um in those months so you've had an
incredible career thus far you're just
in the midst of it too because you're so
young to be the CEO of like a massive
massive firm
um this book take back your power I mean
there's a lot of you in it there's
certainly a lot of heart in it and
personal messages that I think just
about anyone could relate to
um what would you like people to take
away from from this book
both women who want to succeed in
various environments and men who want to
be better you know I would say that you
have for women you have so much more
power than you think you do you know I
talk about yes do you have less power in
certain circumstances absolutely but you
have so much more power than you imagine
every single day and so if you just took
those opportunities if you you showed up
when you're in meetings if you if you
really just speak up when you feel like
you need to those are just moments that
you can take back your power and so I
wrote this because I was that person who
needed this book the most over the last
20 years and I wrote it for all the
things that I wish I had been told when
I left school and I went out into the
workplace and I think for men you know
incredible allies are how people succeed
and if you can be an incredible Ally a
great husband I am only where I am I use
the quote from Cheryl in the beginning
of the chapter about marriage and and
partner ship and I said you know the
most important career decision you make
is who you marry and that has been
absolutely true for me David has been
you know I would not be here
you know the The Wind Beneath Your Wings
as they say like it really is the person
who is carrying you forward in invisibly
and I I say that it's kind of cheesy but
I say that because it is that invisible
support that we all need to succeed in
in our workplace and in life and I feel
like we underestimate how important that
is well you're a remarkable role model
an example for other people uh to
emulate really uh personally and
professionally I mean I've I've met your
family and they're freaking uh happy and
prosperous and you have this phenomenal
organization that you're the head of uh
I can't believe you've already
accomplished so much uh and you're
you're still just in the the midst of it
just uh you know like and I was gonna
say just starting out but you're sort of
in the middle
I I suppose
um take back your power 10 new rules for
women at work uh Deb so excited for you
and your message and your progress uh
and I can't wait to see what you do next
thank you so much Angie